a form of
at least in part involuntary sufferings
depression
do you have advice for people on how to
find a way out
here a man who has suffered in this way
perhaps continue to suffer in this way
how do you find a way out
the first thing I do as a clinician if
someone comes to me and says they're
depressed is ask myself a question
well what does this person mean by that
so I have to find out like because maybe
they're not depressed maybe they're
hyper anxious or maybe they're
obsessional like there's various forms
of powerful negative emotion so they
need to be differentiated but then the
next question you have to ask is well
are you depressed
or do you have a terrible life
or is it some combination of the two
so if you're depressed
as far as I can tell you don't have a
terrible life
you have friends you have family you
have an intimate relationship you have a
job or a career you're about as educated
as you should be given your intelligence
use your time outside of work wisely
you're not beholden to alcohol or other
Temptations
um you're engaged in the community in
some fundamental sense and all that's
working
now if you have all that and you're
feeling really awful you're either ill
or you're depressed
and so then sometimes there's a
biochemical route to that treatment of
that my experience as being as a
clinician is if you're depressed but you
have a life and you take an
antidepressant it will probably help you
a lot
now maybe you're not depressed exactly
you just have a terrible life what does
that look like
you have no relationship your family is
a mess
you've got no friends
you've got no plan you've got no job
you use your time outside of work not
only badly but destructively you have a
drug or alcohol habit or some other Vice
pornography addiction
um you are completely unengaged in the
surrounding Community you have no
scaffolding whatsoever to support you in
your current mode of being or you move
forward and then
as a therapist well you do two things
well if it's depression
per se well like I said there's
sometimes a biochemical root a
nutritional route there's ways that can
be addressed it's probably physiological
if you're at least in part if you're
depressed but you have an okay life
sometimes it's conceptual
you can turn to dreams sometimes to help
people because dreams contain the seeds
of the potential future and if your
person is a real good dreamer and you
can analyze dreams that can be really
helpful but that seems to be only true
for more creative people
and for the people who just have a
terrible life it's like okay
you have a terrible life
well
let's pick a front
how about you need how about you need a
friend like one sort of friend do you
know how to shake hands and introduce
yourself
I'll have the person show me
so let's do it for a sec so
it's like this hi I'm Jordan
and people don't know how to do that and
then they can't even get the ball
rolling for The Listener Jordan just
gave me a firm handshake yeah as opposed
to a dead fish
you know and and there's these
Elementary social skills that
hypothetically if you were well cared
for you learned when you were like three
and sometimes people have I had lots of
clients
to whom no one ever paid any attention
and they needed like ten thousand hours
of attention and some of that was just
listening because they had ten thousand
hours of conversations they never had
with anyone and they were all tangled up
in their head and they had to just
one client in particular I worked with
this person for 15 years
and
what she wanted from me was for me just
to shut the hell up for 50 minutes was
very hard for me and to just tell me
what had happened to her and then what
happened at the end of the conversation
then I could
discuss a bit with her
and then as we we progressed through the
years the amount of time that we spent
in discussion increased in proportion in
this sessions until by the time we
stopped seeing each other when my
clinical practice collapsed
we were talking about 80 percent of the
time but she literally she'd never been
attended to properly ever and so she was
an uncarved Block in the Taoist sense
right she hadn't been subjected to those
flaming swords that separated the wheat
from the chaff
and so
you can do that in therapy if you're
listening and you're depressed I would
say if you can't
find a therapist and that's getting
harder and harder because it's actually
become illegal to be a therapist now
because you have to agree with your
clients which is a terrible thing to do
with them
just like it's terrible just arbitrarily
oppose them
you could do the self-authoring program
online because it helps you write an
autobiography
and so if you have memories that are
more than 18 months old that bother you
when you think them up
part of you is locked inside that an un
developed part of you is still trapped
in that that's a metaphorical way of
thinking about that's why it still has
emotional significance so you can write
about your past experiences but I would
say wait for at least 18 months if
something bad has happened to you
because otherwise you just hurt yourself
again by encountering it
you can bring yourself up to date with
an autobiography there's an analysis of
faults and virtues that's the present
authoring and then there's a guided
writing exercise that helps you make a
future plan
that's
young men who do that could go to
college young men who do that 90 minutes
just the future all three 90 minutes
they're 50 percent less likely to drop
out that's all it takes
so sometimes depression is the is this
heavy Cloud that makes it hard to even
make a single step towards it or you
said isolate make a friend oh man
sometimes my first step is extremely
difficult oh my God sometimes it's it's
way worse than that like I had clients
who were so depressed they literally
couldn't get out of bed
so what's their first step it's like can
you sit up
once today no
can you prop yourself up on your elbows
once today like you just you scale back
the Dragon
until you find one that's conquerable
that moves you forward there's a there's
a rubric for Life scale back the dragons
till you find one conquerable and it'll
give you a little bit of gold
commensurate with the struggle but the
plus side of that because that's you
think that God that's depressing you
mean I have to start by sitting up
well you do if you can't sit up
but the the plus side of that is it's
the Pareto distribution issue is that
aggregates
exponentially increase and failures do
too by the way but Aggregates
exponentially increase so once you start
the ball rolling it can get zipping
along pretty good this person that I
talked about
was incapable of sitting with me in a
cafe when we first met just talking even
though I was her therapist but by the
end
she was doing stand-up comedy
so
you know it took years but
still most people won't do stand-up
comedy that's that's quite the bloody
achievement she she would read her
poetry on stage too
so for someone who is petrified into
paralysis by social anxiety
and who had to start very small
there's a hell of an accomplishment